we just want to encourage you guys that
it's going to be okay and that that was
the message and to control the
controllables you get you do one of the
things that is worth talking about you
know in this segment is that there's a
tremendous power emotionally spiritually
when you do what you can do that they
have you know what you can control you
control those things and my old friend
art Williams always said all you can do
is all you can do and that's enough yeah
it gets overwhelming when you start to
think about everything even just on a
higher level right so you start thinking
nationally what's going on in Washington
to even a state level and and it's just
like oh there's some there can be so
much to fret about and so much to worry
about but when you actually kind of let
go of that control and say okay there
are things that I just I I don't have
control over I mean if they're doing
something I can't I can't do anything
about it but here's what I can do and we
kind of walk through like controlling
your attitude controlling your money and
controlling your opportunities like
those are things that you can be
purposeful and today that we really
spoke into but man it just it gives you
a sense of peace when you know I can do
something about this if you choose
generosity in the form of a smile if you
choose kindness instead of ripping
everybody in your neighborhood face
judgment I hate to say it we talked
about it last night people have gone
absolutely crazy and I and I kind of
intersected last night just talking
about giving grace to people like on
both extremes both sides need to look at
each other so you know what that's what
that's how they're choosing to handle it
and just giving them grace because even
on our next door app thing it was like
two neighborhoods down from us there
were kids playing on a playground and
you would have thought the end of the
world was happy I mean like people are
just mad at each other on both sides I
mean they're just biting each other and
I'm like oh my goodness
like just take a deep breath control
what you can control those aren't your
children out there probably on that
playground but like it is there's an
element those children are going to
bring the end to the earth that we've
lost we've lost our minds so it's just
the ability to be kind that's it it's
just not to be ashamed of yourself well
and it's just pulling back the judgments
I mean
I think honestly at a time like this I'm
like it's what you tell your kids but
it's like you you know you have enough
to take care of for yourself what's the
saying um taking care of yourself as a
full-time job that's it but you have a
full-time job taking care of yourself
and those kids if they're not your kids
or nunya nunya business well you would
have been on that extreme unloved debate
I mean there's not a public health
crisis they're children on a playground
that's just asinine right well it's just
it's the attitudes of the unkindness
that just floods out of people so yeah
that's it I mean just take a deep breath
to give people grace and but that's not
running in every HOA across America
right now I'm sure yeah it's just I mean
every single one's got you know Barney
Fife of the coronavirus is is gone to
town because Barney's afraid and if
you're Barney right now and you decided
you're in charge of everybody else but
because you're afraid you need to take a
breath be calm you can only control you
you can't control all those people even
if you're right right nothing to control
them yep and knowing where that's coming
out of I mean I can't control what
Donald Trump does right even if I
disagree with him and I'm right I can't
control what Nancy Pelosi does even if I
disagree with her and I'm right they're
gonna do what they're going to do no
matter how angry or unkind or nasty I
post on Twitter or how much I I mean to
my own relatives because they said
something like that or did something
like that this is just it's ridiculous
it's gotten out of hand and so you're
right controlling your attitude and
giving grace being generous to people
with a smile let's go you know what I
get that you feel that way but I don't
and I'm not doing that
yep and so you know I I get I understand
your concern but I I'm looking at this
view I'm viewing this difference that's
right yeah and I think that the fear is
just so heightened it comes out in anger
and aggression it comes on so anyway so
I think that's when you can recognize
that and just say and what it does is it
whether it's fear on the economics side
or whether it's fear on the virus side
when it when you're in when you just go
into hyperventilation mode hysteria mode
you just you you leave all the facts
behind in either case you leave all the
facts behind and and you you are
revealing the weakness in your character
when you're mean to people in those
situations or shaming people in those
situations and so you know our team went
home we've sent them home to work from
home last Friday they've been home a
week now but we didn't do that soon
enough to suit some people that and so
the names that our family has been
called and the things that people have
threatened us because because we didn't
move our team home as soon as they
thought we should well we were trying to
do is keep enough revenue coming in to
be able to feed all these 1,000 families
that count on us but the way people have
reacted it's just unconscionable and
it's I mean the tapes I'm called on
Twitter all the time anyway Twitter to
start with Twitter is just a it's just a
yes for trolls you don't need it yeah
but you don't get on Instagram yeah is
if they don't say nasty stuff on
Instagram they really don't know not as
much not as much I'll go with you very
kind no no not always but yeah but I
mean they just give yourself right give
other folks ok that's your thing yep and
this is mine
lots of compassion and you know you can
vote that way I'll vote this way and and
no one's being killed by either thing
just think something today you know
somebody ripping somebody about that
didn't think we ought to go back to work
and the guy said if we don't all go back
to work there's gonna be mass suicides
because of the economic stuff
come on I mean together there's always
suicides which is horrible
but I mean come on you don't have to
overstate your case to make a solid case
on something besides that you're arguing
somebody's already made up their minds
stop doing that that's that's a waste of
your energy